that's why Federal authorities say he's
in the U.S illegally and has re-entered
multiple times I'm going to call Carlos
Nava Carlos Nava here for his case
dating back to July Metro Police say he
sexually assaulted and kidnapped a woman
he was buying sex from turns out Navas
now accused of four additional sexual
assaults one of them a cold case from
2003. Mr Nava now essentially might have
as much as combined Act of sexual
assaults and all of these sexual
assaults involve an individuals who was
working as a processor at that time
prosecutor William Rawls says Nava's DNA
matches those cases the 8 news now
investigators learned those crimes are
alleged to have happened while he was in
the U.S illegally according to
Immigration and Customs Enforcement he's
re-entered at least eight times since
2002. this is an email from an ice
spokesperson describing Nava's history
you can see how long it is Nava's been
discovered by law enforcement in
California Arizona and Las Vegas arrests
include charges for battery and domestic
violence the last known time novel was
in the U.S and then removed in 2020
after his arrest last July records
showed judge Daniel westmeyer granted
bail Nava was placed on electronic
monitoring and was able to walk out of
jail that's while police said they were
looking for more victims
sexual assaulted members of our
community since 2003 Nava learning about
the new allegations against him through
an interpreter the victim in the initial
case a no-show
individuals
because there are more alleged victims
including one under the age of 16 years
old police in plain clothes were
standing by ready to take Nava into
custody again
foreign
the judge saying if the victim in that
first case doesn't show up here in court
to testify that case will be dismissed
reporting in downtown Las Vegas at the
Regional Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now